hacer en este vídeo son dos
parametrización es de la misma curva
pero a diferencia vamos a hacer que le
inquiere el incremento en cada curva sea
distinto y así podamos tener una mejor
intuición de lo que significa la
derivada de una función vectorial así
que vamos a decir que mi primera
parametrización digamos que es x dt
igual at&t igual a t cuadrada muy bien
entonces en realidad estamos hablando de
dos funciones escalares donde está
definida entre 0 y digamos 2 ahora si
quiere escribir esto como un vector de
posición donde donde t es nuestro
parámetro y nos va dando en qué punto de
la curva nos vamos colocando pues
podemos decir que nuestra función es r
digamos r 1 que es nuestra primer
parametrización r1 de t va a ser igual
a x1 dt que esté por el vector y que es
el unitario en la dirección x más de uno
de t por el vector j que en realidad es
t cuadrada de cuadrada por el vector
unitario jota que va en la dirección del
eje y y voy a hacer muy cuidadoso con
esto con los gráficos porque realmente
quiero que se entienda que es la
derivada cuál es su significado
así que pondré pondré mis ejes digamos
que aquí está el 1 el 2 el 3 y el 4
sobre el eje y y ahora ponemos el eje x
es muy bueno y aquí está el 1 el 2 con
esto basta así entre igual a cero cuáles
son las coordenadas de nuestra función
bueno cuando te vale cero pues equis
vale cero y también verdad así que
tenemos el punto cero coma cero entre
igual aún no tenemos x igual a 1 y ye
igual a 1 también así que tenemos el
punto 1,1
ahora cuando te vale 2 tenemos en x 2
unidades y en que tenemos 2 al cuadrado
que son 4 así que en la dirección x este
es nuestro primer vector y en la
dirección que tenemos nuestro vector de
cuatro unidades es decir este otro
correcto así que nuestro último punto es
el 2,4 muy bien lo colocamos ahí
entonces el vector va en este aspecto
verdad nada más para que se vea más
claro pintándolo como flechita esto es r
1 de 2 evaluado en 2 verdad este el
origen es r 1 en 0
y bueno lo que se ve es que esto es una
parábola verdad esta sería la ruta que
recorre el punto al moverse bajo esta
regla esta es la primera parametrización
ahora permítanme deshacerme de todas
estas flechas nada más me voy a quedar
con el dibujo de lo que de la parábola
muy bien lo voy a hacer mejor
voy a deshacerme de los puntos nada más
y ahí está
muy bien así que esta es mi parábola y
puede mirarse algo parecido muy bien
esta fue la primera parametrización
ahora voy a hacer esta misma curva pero
voy a hacerlo ligeramente diferente así
que vamos a hacer esto en colores
distintos
digamos que x2 dt va a ser 12 y que 2 dt
en este caso va a ser 2 t al cuadrado
que es no es otra cosa más que 4 t
cuadrada verdad también lo podemos
escribir así como 4 t cuadrado ahora
esto esto simplemente resultó de elevar
estos dos a la misma potencia que es 2
verdad ahora digamos que en lugar de
empezar que o que te vaya entre 0 y 1
eso es lo que quiero decir es decir el
tiempo se va a recorrer entre 0 y 1 y
vamos a tener la misma ruta nuestra
segunda posición vectorial digamos r 2
dt va a ser x2 dt por y que es
2 t por nuestro vector y más de 2 dt que
es 4 t cuadrada por j
muy bien así que cuál es la gráfica
bueno
parecería que vamos a tener que pintar
nuestros ejes nuevamente digamos este es
el eje y
muy bien y este es el eje x vamos a
hacer el dibujo de lo que son las
derivadas y todo ponemos cuatro unidades
luego uno dos y con esto basta así que
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando te es igual
a cero cuando t es igual a cero en x se
hace cero y en jet también así que en
realidad lo que tenemos es el punto cero
cero el origen ahora cuando t es igual a
un medio en la posición x tenemos un
medio de 2 es 1 y en la posición ya
tenemos un medio al cuadrado que es un
cuarto por cuatro y lo que nos queda es
uno muy bien así que cuando t es un
medio tenemos el punto 1,1 y por último
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando te es igual
a 1 cuando t es igual a 1 estamos en el
mismo punto final que en el caso
anterior así que la misma curva vamos a
tener en esta otra parametrización
ahora quiero pensar en lo siguiente
vamos a pensar que nuestro parámetro t
realmente es el tiempo es el tiempo y
que de hecho es la interpretación más
común que encontramos pero bueno digamos
que es el tiempo en lo que está
sucediendo cada una de las curvas verdad
es como me voy moviendo a lo largo del
tiempo a lo largo de estas de estas
líneas
ok podemos imaginar un punto que se va
moviendo a lo largo de de estas curvas
y que es en este caso segundo este punto
es capaz de cubrir la misma línea pero
en menos tiempo verdad aquí nos lleva de
0 a 1 mientras que en el caso anterior
de 0 a 2
en esta segunda parametrización a pesar
de que la ruta de acceso era la misma
las curvas son iguales en este caso el
punto es más rápido ok
hay que tener en mente que cuando
pensamos en la derivada de ambos
vectores de posición de estas funciones
en en realidad recordemos que el punto
se mueve más rápido cada vez que nos
movemos en esta curva verdad ahora
veamos la derivada de estos dos chicos
veamos así que la derivada de este
realmente la derivada de r1 de t
déjenme permítanme utilizar otro color
mejor
déjenme hacerlo en azul digamos la
derivada de r1
la derivada de r1 recordemos que la
derivada es la derivada de cada una de
las componentes verdad así que la
derivada de la primera es 1 por i
ahora vamos a sumarle la derivada de la
segunda componente que en este caso es
la derivada de t cuadrada es 2 t y
multiplicamos por jota vamos a
aprovechar la derivada de esto ahora
hagamos la derivada de r2 la derivada de
la primera componente es 2 x más la
derivada de la segunda es 4 por la
derivada de t cuadrada que es 2 t y 4
por 2 es 8 así que tenemos que la
derivada será 8
por j
8 t por jota muy bien ahora la pregunta
es que que hace cada una de estas
derivadas que por qué son tan distintas
y son la misma curva así que vamos a
mirar no sé vamos a ver qué tan rápido
se mueve en uno digamos en el punto 1,1
de esta primera así que en realidad
estamos tomando té igual a 1 por lo que
el vector derivada del vector derivada
de este punto en el punto 11
vamos a hacerlo en el 11 verdad en cada
una de las parametrización es así que en
este lugar estamos pensando en el tiempo
1 mientras que en el segundo en el
tiempo igual a un medio ahora r 1 en 1
sabemos que la derivada de r1 en uno es
1 y más 2 y evaluamos de igual a 1 así
que es 2 j
así que en este momento la derivada de
nuestra función tiene como componente en
x1 y como componente en y 2 así que
sacamos este vector poniendo esta suma
de vectores
esta suma de dos vectores
colocamos un vector anclado en este
punto que llega hasta este que
encontramos que es el 1 2 1 y perdón + 2
j déjenme lo pinto mejor
exacto yo lo que quiero es que se vea
que en realidad están gente a la curva y
que va en dirección en la misma
dirección en la que la partícula se va
moviendo ahora está este vector derivada
es el 1 y más 2 j este es la derivada de
r1 en el punto de igual a uno correcto
cuando te vale 1 cuando el tiempo ha
recorrido un segundo ahora analicemos la
misma posición en esta segunda
parametrización y bueno como ya dijimos
aquí es cuando el tiempo ha transcurrido
medio segundo así que vamos a tomar
vamos a hacerlo con el mismo color la
derivada de r2
evaluado en un medio
correcto así que la derivada de r2
evaluado en un medio es 2 y más más 88
por de que vale un medio así que es 4
verdad 4 por jota así que qué es lo que
estamos viendo la derivada instantánea
en este punto está muy relacionada con
el caso anterior déjenme lo pinto en
este caso nos movemos 2 en la dirección
x y 4 en la dirección
muy bien obtenemos este punto por lo que
al pegar estos dos puntitos que nos
definen nuestro nuestro vector déjenme
ver si me sale bien o algo así
muy bien
más o menos no no no lo estoy dibujando
tan claro como me gustaría pero bueno
vamos a notar algo estos dos vectores
van en la misma dirección tienen la
misma ruta tangencial a nuestra curva en
eso en eso no debe haber duda pero este
vector tiene una magnitud mucho más
grande que la magnitud del vector
anterior de hecho es el doble y eso
tiene mucho sentido porque cuando
hablábamos de las funciones y sus
derivadas y demás esta longitud del
vector podemos interpretarlo como la
rapidez la longitud será igual a la
rapidez que si te has imaginado esto con
respecto al tiempo y las parametrización
es representan un punto que se mueve a
lo largo de la curva en este caso la
partícula tiene una velocidad o una
rapidez mucho mayor así que si lo
piensas el vector de acá lo podemos
imaginar como en realidad una velocidad
una velocidad
y esa es la dirección que lleva la
velocidad la otra el tamaño vamos a
considerarlo la rapidez ok en este caso
si éste usamos el teorema de pitágoras
para calcular la la magnitud de estos
vectores pero lo que quiero que vean es
que en realidad basta con ver que éste
es mucho más grande así que esperemos
que ahora tengas esto muy claro y que se
te haya quedado hasta en las tripas